hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new iphone 12 pro and today we're
going to be comparing it against the
iphone 11 pro
but this isn't your typical comparison
not only are we going to be covering the
differences in design
size performance and those standard kind
of things but we're going to be touching
on things that nobody
has covered yet such as the speakers
we're going to cover the lte speeds not
only how much faster 5g is
but how much faster is the 4g modem in
here if you're in an area that doesn't
have 5g
because that's also been updated we're
also going to be doing things
like testing out max safe and we're
going to see if we actually are getting
15 watts out of this
if you guys didn't see the previous
video yesterday you might want to check
that out
and answering the question if you don't
buy apple's new
20 watt usb type-c charger do you still
get 15 watts or is it slower
and how much slower as you guys know
there is no
charger or earpods included in the box
and apple says it's to help the
environment but we think the main reason
is in order to keep the pro
at 9.99 while giving it the best
5g chip on the market instead of hiking
up the price
like most android phones and because
they're getting rid of those accessories
and we just have this lightning to
usb cable the size of the box is half
the size which saves a ton of space in
warehousing
which in turn helps the environment and
saves apple a lot of money
now i have to comment on this um i was
kind of skeptical about the square edge
i know vadim
you were super hyped about it but man
this thing looks and feels
amazing right away i'm noticing two
different things
first off it feels more comfortable in
the hand than i expected
with these square edges and two it feels
thicker than i expected the iphone 11
pro is 8.1 millimeters whereas
this new 12 pro is 7.4
that is the thinnest phone in years
and interestingly before this i was
checking out the se which is 7.3
just slightly thinner and i was
expecting this new phone to feel
close to the se but it doesn't at all
that's because having these rounded
edges like on the se
and the previous iphones the 11 pro it
kind of gives you an illusion of
thinness
whereas this thing is significantly
thinner but it feels
thicker another surprise is that the 12
pro doesn't feel any heavier
despite it being larger and having this
larger 6.1 inch display
and comparing the width they are
surprisingly basically identical despite
having a larger display
due to the new design the height is
barely changed so if you're worrying
about having a larger phone with the 12
pro
don't worry the buttons are lower from
the top than before so they're still
going to be easy to access
and along with that they do feel a
little bit nicer a little bit more
clicky on both sides now that was moved
over from the right hand side
to the left and that's because we have
this new additional antenna
four millimeter wave 5g and as for the
bottom we are losing
one of the little speaker girl cutouts
on the 12 pro
the camera bump is a little bit larger
and the lenses are slightly larger
to be proportionate now with that
it actually sticks out more so because
the phone is thinner
and if we line them up on the desk the
actual lenses are at the same exact
level the flash is also larger and we
have this new
lidar sensor but it's interesting that
the microphone little hole here
is much much smaller so we're gonna have
to test out the audio quality
take a look at the front let's go ahead
and power it on and you'll notice a
couple things first off
the bezels are quite a bit thinner
that's because the glass on the front
now is completely
flat whereas before it was curved around
the edges to meet the frame
meaning the apple had to stop the
display earlier before that curve
now another thing that really stands out
is with this new 12
pro the glass literally meets the frame
and you can't even tell
a difference so the frame is not
protecting the front
but it does feel very nice now the notch
is identical on
both of them but because the bezels are
thinner when we stack them up side by
side we do
actually have more room on the sides of
the notch the new 6.1 inch display isn't
that much
larger than the 5.8 in terms of screen
real estate so you might want to look at
the pro
max if you wanted more space and i do
want to mention that the glass is using
new ceramic
shield which apple says is four times
stronger now let's test out magsafe
this is what apple is advertising very
heavily it's a new kind of killer
feature
with the new iphones and they even sent
out all the reviewers these magnetic
sheets so they can show off the magnets
my curiosity is how much stronger is the
connection on an iphone
compared to the case that we tested out
previously so i had that feel right
there
yeah actually i definitely noticed a
difference pulling up
with the case you actually can feel that
it's not
that difficult i mean we still have a
solid connection but then taking mac
safe
and connecting to the phone this is the
amount of pressure i'm applying to the
case causing it to pop
off but on here wow that's a much more
solid
feel and that is fantastic so let's go
ahead and test out with the case here
go ahead and pop it on and that was a
lot easier putting the case on compared
to
older generations okay it almost feels
like it's amplified but even you're
saying maybe it's going to help
the connection it feels like it's even
stronger using a case with magsafe
than just the phone and then of course
the case by itself is really weak
and now let's test out the new magsafe
charging and see how much faster it is
compared to the older iphones using
standard 7.5 watt charging i'm going to
start out with the new
20 watt usbc brick and then i'm also
going to test
what do you get if you're using the 18
watt that a lot of people out there
have the results are in and wow i was
not expecting this
we have 5 watts with the standard qi
charger
and with this one i actually got 7.5 on
my 11 pro max
so maybe it's not perfectly aligned on
here whereas max safe it's always going
to be perfectly aligned
but with magsafe and that 20 watt brick
we're seeing 11.76
so basically 12 watt wireless charging
now this could be for a couple
of reasons the one that i probably think
is the
the most likely is that we are at 79
percent
and we don't know when apple is tapering
down that 15 watt wireless charging
down to 12 or even slower now we are
going to be doing a detailed comparison
between max safe charging
and fast lightning wireless charging and
then even a slow brick
and then we'll see a full grab zero two
hundred percent how much faster it is
overall
and where that tapers down so make sure
you guys subscribe
if you guys want to check out that video
now let's go ahead and test out using
the 18 watt brick
and we have the results with the 18 watt
power brick and this app is showing
9.29 watts uh with this 18 water now
at this point we're at 82 charge so once
again it doesn't tell the full story
make sure you're subscribed and have
those notifications enabled for a
detailed charge comparison
we're actually buying physical wattage
meters so that's going to be an
excellent video getting back to the
displays the spec sheet says that
they're pretty much identical
but we did find some surprising
differences
the typical brightness is the same 800
nits but
one thing that we do notice is that
there is a white balance
difference and this is what true tone
turned on and without true tone we see
that the display
is actually warmer on the new 12 pro
now that's not the only difference if we
take a look at viewing angles
the iphone 11 pro actually starts
turning quite a bit more blue if you
start looking off axis
whereas the 12 pro is now very
consistent so that's a nice improvement
i do want to mention that we do not have
pro motion on the new iphone 12
which we really wanted to have but with
that said
based on the battery life results which
we'll talk about in just a bit it makes
sense why apple didn't add it and now
it's time for our speaker comparison
apple didn't mention that there were any
changes but we're gonna test it out
anyways
so go ahead and put on a nice pair of
headphones and
let's take a listen
[Music]
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below i'll give you guys
my opinion because
we're hearing it here first hand and we
actually got some good
improvements in every single way and i
was not expecting it now maybe the
module itself is the same or the modules
maybe it's just the new design that
helps but we noticed that the highs
are more crisp they're a little bit more
sharp it's louder
the mids are more rich and we have more
bass as well
which is nice and we test it out using
my decibel meter on my apple watch
and the iphone 11 pro peaked at 81
decibels
and we got a peak of 83 on the new 12
pro so that's a two decibel difference
and that is a nice improvement
and now let's get into performance and
we're going to start with what apple is
pushing like crazy
and that is 5g so i'm going to go ahead
and put my t-mobile sim
in here and we're going to do some speed
comparisons now a lot of people are
saying
that 5g doesn't matter they don't have
5g in the area
but this new iphone 12 has a newer
modem it's a snapdragon modem so even if
you don't have 5g
the 4g should be faster so we're going
to test both of those
let's go ahead and get started i am
connected to the same server
both are connected to t-mobile and for
the old iphone
we're getting three bars but we're only
getting two bars for the 5g with the
iphone 12. but look at that speed
difference
wow so we're looking at 2.3 compared to
40.
oh that just went down to one bar and i
have to say that we are in a city right
now where we're having a snowstorm
outside
usually our reception would be a little
bit faster here indoors and 5g
we have just a slow version the sub 6
but that really helps penetrate walls
and through different things
and maybe that's helping with the snow
outside because look at that difference
now the upload isn't that different
but the download speeds from 2.3
to 45 and we are in a concrete building
as well so
in bad conditions that's a massive
difference so we just went outside and
tested this on the roof
and look at this difference as far as
download
we're getting 28 on the iphone 11 pro
and 65
on the 12 pro upload we have a massive
91 which is
the fastest i've ever seen here um and
then
for the 11 pro max it got 49 now if you
look at this graph the 5g was extremely
consistent whereas the 11 pro
it actually was running at about 20 for
the upload and as soon as r12 pro got
finished
it went up to 49 which is also very good
now of course
your results are going to vary based on
your city we have pretty slow speeds
here in spokane
but with those slow speeds the 5g phone
the new iphone 12 is getting
really impressive results and now for
those of you guys that don't have 5g in
your city
let's go ahead and go into the cellular
data options and we're going to go ahead
and turn off 5g
we're just going to go to the lte that
way
we'll be able to test if you'll get any
improvements just with your standard lte
let's get started we're connected to the
same server and one
interesting thing is that in lte mode
our iphone 12 pro only has two bars
instead of
three with the 11 pro but look at the
speed difference
how could this be possible if we only
have two bars instead of three
actually i know it's the modem we have a
snapdragon
x55 modem the best currently on the
market compared to an intel modem
which is i've been disappointed last
couple years if you guys saw my reviews
and we did another test outside it's so
cold out there
and both with lte both had the same five
bars
and look at these speed differences
we're having literally
four times faster download and
twice the upload speed both of them just
using standard
lte because of that new snapdragon
uh lte chip or our modem in here instead
of using intel so
forget about 5g if you don't have 5g
they're marketing it
this is the real results for everybody
that's upgrading
you're gonna get faster download speeds
and people that are in better cities
that have faster lte speeds on the 11
pro
your speeds might double or even triple
that is very impressive and i've never
seen this good
lte speeds here in spokane so if you're
somebody that is suffering with bad
reception
slow speeds bad penetration into
buildings
you can't stream videos very well man
this alone
might be a reason to upgrade to the new
iphone 12s i also want to mention
that i am going to be doing a detailed
comparison between 5g
and 4g using different parts in the city
basements
outdoors so make sure you guys subscribe
if you want to see a much more detailed
look
at the data speeds and now let's test
out this new
a14 processor we're gonna start out with
geekbench
five and the a14 is the first five
nanometer chip on the market
not only is that better performance and
lower power usage
but it also has much faster machine
learning and the results are in i want
to show you guys the 11 pro first
we have 1300 for single and about 3 400
for the multi-core score and with the
iphone 12 pro
we have 1600 for single core and 4200
from multi-core so we have a difference
of slightly more than 20 for single core
which is great
this single core score is the highest
i've ever seen and multi-core score
about 25
faster now not only do we have a
performance difference which
to be honest the a13 is already very
fast
what i care about more is the ram
difference we have four gigs with the 11
pro and six gigs with the 12
pro that means if you're a multitasker
like i am it's going to make sure that
your background apps don't automatically
close
and now let's take a look at graphics
performance
with this new a14 and here's the results
we have 7300 on the 11 pro and 9322 on
the 12 pro
so that's getting close to 30 better
metal performance now i also just
noticed
that we're still running ios 13 on this
specific 11 pro
so i did test out my 11 pro max
with ios 14.1 and i got 7500 slightly
higher
the previous cpu scores were right in
line with what we've gotten
on this one as well to be honest i was
expecting a little bit more after i saw
the ipad air
4 benchmarks with that same a14 which
we're gonna have a video on that coming
up tomorrow
uh but i guess 30 is nothing to laugh
about
so let's go ahead and do a gaming test
this is actually antutu not only will it
simulate
a heavy gaming load but also we're going
to take a look at things like memory
ux and all that kind of stuff and just
looking
at the test running it's really hard to
tell a difference
the results are in and this is a little
weird
the overall score is about 15
faster accounting for everything the cpu
is faster
but looking at the graphics the 12 pro
is actually rated
lower a little bit which might make
sense why i couldn't really see a visual
difference in smoothness
so i have no idea what's going on maybe
this app is not using metal maybe it's
using
opengl so we'll actually have to revisit
this
in our full review of the iphone 12 pro
make sure you guys have those
notifications enabled
for that but one surprising thing is the
memory
our memory score is actually right about
double
it looks like the speeds look at that
the write speed went from 900
to uh what is that 16 000
that's huge and then random access is
close to three two and a half times
faster and the read speed is also
tripled so it looks like not only do we
have six gigs instead of four gigs
the actual memory here is much faster so
it looks like
our ram speed is right about the same
even though we have two extra gigs
that's not what is helping this
the actual storage speed is way faster
maybe that's because we have 128 gig
instead of 64
and upgrades in the chips themselves and
now let's talk about battery life now
obviously we haven't thoroughly tested
it we just got the 11 pro max but
mr who's the boss did an amazing
comparison
and we can get some very good info from
that
now in his testing the 12 pro actually
got one hour
less battery life than the 11 pro which
is disappointing now this is for a
couple of reasons
first off the battery itself in this new
12 pro
is about 230 milliamp hours smaller
and along with that at the same time we
have a larger display
with more pixels and that's where we're
getting that difference
now with that said if you're coming from
an iphone 11 or 10r or previous one
that's still gonna be a really nice jump
in battery life compared to the other
phones and with that one hour loss if
you're somebody that's using 5g
you might actually get a little bit less
battery life because 5g
does take a lot more power but keep in
mind you can go in here
and switch over to the lte if you need
better battery life
and now let's talk about the cameras
now only one of the sensors and cameras
were actually
changed and that is the main shooter
with that one we have
f 1.6 lens instead of f 1.8
and here you guys can see some photos
you guys let me know what looks better
down in the comment section below and
now along with that we have a lot of
software updates we have smart hdr3
we have night mode on all four camera
lenses instead of just
the main one and we have a better
defusion
as well so we will be actually doing a
very detailed comparison
testing out smart hdr and video as well
not only comparing the 12 pro
against the 11 pro but also the iphone
10 s as well that's gonna be a great
video
make sure you guys are subscribed for
that one we do have one edition with the
12 pro and that is the new lidar
scanner now it's not only used for
photos it can be used to scan different
objects
and that's pretty cool but most people
are going to be using it for a better
autofocus and the new portrait
night mode feature so you can finally
combine great low light performance
and still get portrait shots there's a
couple more small little differences
that i want to mention
first off this camera is going to be
able to use dolby vision for video
hdr built in which is great uh we're
also going to have apple pro
raw coming up in a future update and
with that we have some waterproofing
differences
we have ip68 rating with the 11 pro it
goes up to 4 meters
for 30 minutes now it can go up to 6
meters
and with that let's finish off with
prices and my
final verdict and the prices are staying
the same
999 dollars and i know some people are
upset the apple is not including the
charger in the box
or the earpods that nobody used and that
is kind of a bummer but you know what
with apple keeping the prices the same
compared to a lot of the android
competitors that hike up the prices with
5g
and the fact that they're using the best
5g chip and even if they don't have 5g
the lte is way faster
i think that is incredible and with that
same price we have double the storage
128 gigs it's about three times faster
and that alone right there is sweet
because that is the sweet spot before
you have to spend 150 bucks more
you're forced to get 256 which i didn't
do
128 is awesome so is it worth upgrading
from an iphone 11 pro
to the 12 pro and i have to say
absolutely now i know vadim was very
excited about this new model
i wasn't as excited but now that i have
it in my hands it looks great it feels
great not only do we have a lot of
performance improvements from the cpus
to the graphics to the lte and 5g speeds
but we also have better speakers
we have better glass that's stronger the
viewing angles are better
there's a ton of improvements along with
the cameras
i i gotta say this is a killer update
and if you have an 11 pro
i think there's a lot of reason to
upgrade so thank you guys for watching
let us know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below go ahead and click that
circle above to subscribe
if you guys want to see a lot more
videos on these new phones we have some
great ones coming up
and check out one of the two videos over
there this been max and i'll see you in
the next video